today we humans are simple individual
life-forms that are beginning to bring
technology into our bodies whether it's
the cell phone or eventually brain
computer interface that will ultimately
allow us to link together and to what I
think of as the meta intelligence of the
future where I'll begin to have full
cognitive knowledge you know search will
be something instantaneous I'll think
about it and know what's going on but
more so I'll have knowledge of you know
what a sunrise looks like right now in
Japan and what people are feeling in
other parts of the world the benefit
thereof is to create sort of a level of
total human consciousness that's never
been understood before
the richness of our minds in the
uniqueness of ourselves comes from the
unique connections we make inside of our
own individual memory as we begin to
kind of pay less attention to building
our own memory because we're so
dependent on and so used to using the
web to find stuff we not only risk
eroding the richness of our personal
lives but i think we risk eroding some
of the basic foundations of the richness
of culture as well
you